بيت الله الحرام
ووصف
هذا المسجد وواصف بناء هذا المسجد
واخذ صوره من الحياه
واوائل ايامه صلى الله عليه وسلم بالمدينه
مع اصحابه
روى الامام البخاري
رحمه الله تعالى في صحيحه بسنده
ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم دخل
المدينه راكبا راحلته
فسار يمشي معه الناس
حتى بركت عند مسجد رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم بالمدينه يعني عند المكان الذي
كتب الله بناء هذا المسجد
وهو يصلي فيه يومئذ الرجال من المسلمين
وكان مربدا للتمر
فهذا يعني كان قطعه من الارض حائطا
وكان مربدا للتمر يعني يجففون التمر في
هذا المكان
ويؤهبون انواعا من التمر للبيع
وكان بعض الصحابه رضي الله عنهم يذهبون
الى هذه البقعه بما انها معزوله شيئا ما
عن طريق الناس
ويجتمعون في هذه الارض ويصلون فيها
وهذه
الارض
يقول البخاري وكان مربدا للتمر
لسهل وسهيل
غلامين يتيمين في حجر اسعد بن زراره
فقال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
حين بركت به راحلته هذا ان شاء الله
المنزل
ثم دعا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الغلامين
فساومهما بالمربد ليتخذه مسجد مسجدا يعني
يريد ان يبتاعه هذا المربد
ويجعله وقفا للمسلمين ومكان مسجده صلى
الله عليه وسلم
والغلامان كان مسلمين فقال لا بل نهبه لك
يا رسول الله
فابى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ان
يقبله منهما هبه حتى ابتاعه منهما
وهذا يعود الى
مساله في خلق الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ولعل ثم
اسباب اخرى لهذا لكن من
خلقه عليه الصلاه والسلام
انه اذا سال عن شيء او سال احد الناس عن
شيء يريد ان يشتريه
فانه المتوقع
انهم ما يبيعوا انهم يقولوا لا خذها يا
رسول مهما كانت
ونعلم من الصحابه ان نفوسهم كانت زكيه
وفعلا لا يجدون في انفسهم حرجا ان يهبوا
لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم حتى
ارواحهم لكن
ليس من المروءه
ان تاخذ من احد شيئا بما يقال سيف الحياه
ايش يعني سيف الحياه يعني مثلا عالم او
كبير او انسان له جاه عظيم عند الناس
المتوقع انه ما طلب من الناس فان الناس
عاده لا يريدون يتحرجون ان يبيعون وانما
يعطوا
يعطوا وممكن حدا نفسه ما تكون يعني تماما
مطمئنا بهذه يحس انه يعني انا
يعني انا في مازق في ضيق يعني اخذ منه
وابتاع
او ابيعه هذا الشيء لكن في نفسي من هذا
حرج الى اخره
فالاصل في خلق الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وفي سنته حتى مع اقرب الصحابه اليه انه
اذا طلب شيئا
فانه
ياخذه بثمنه
فما كما فعل مع ابي بكر
ابو بكر رضي الله عنه كان
صاحب الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم عمرا
طويلا
قبل البعثه
كان
صاحبا لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قراب
38 سنه
قبل
رساله وقبل البعثه قبل نبوته
هذه صداقه عمر ابو بكر رضي الله عنه ولد
بعد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم بسنتين
ونشا معا
هذا اقرب الناس اليه لما جاء
ليخبر ابا بكر رضي الله عنه
باذن الله وبامر الله بالهجره
وقال له ابو بكر الصحبه قال الصحبه يعني
انا واياك نهاجر مع بعض
فقال له ابو بكر
خذ
خير
راحلتي هاتين
اركبها يعني في الطريق
فقال صلى الله عليه وسلم لا بل بالثمن
وابى الا يدفع حك
الراحله وهذا من اقرب الناس اليه
لكن اذا انسان
جاءه
والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لم يعرض له
بشيء ولم
ينبئ هذا الانسان
يعني انه نفسه في شيء وجاء هذا الانسان
منه لنفسه اجى واعطاه هبه يقبل الهديه
يقبل الهديه بشرط الا يخشى منا من المعطي
لانه بعض الاعراب
كانوا يدخلون في الاسلام
ويهبون لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
هبات
وهم ينتظرون المكافاه
ينتظرون المكافاه يعني من الخلق وعارفين
انه خلق الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
المكافاه
وهو امر اصحابه بالمكافاه
فامرنا ان
احدا منا اذا اعطي شيئا ان يكافئ المعطي
فان لم يستطع فليدعو له
فالمقصود انه اذا جاء احد منه لنفسه
وهب لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم شيئا
فانه لا يرد هذه الهديه
لا يردها الا ان خشي منا من المعطي بعضهم
كان يطمع في كرم الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
يجي ويعطيه الشيء
والحديث في عند البخاري في الادب المفرد
ان اعربيا وهب له شيئا او اعطاه هديه
ثم كافه رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم مما
وجد من سعته
فاستح
قر ذلك العطاء الاعرابي يعني ما عبى عينه
كان طامع في اكثر
من هيك
فوجد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم منه هذا
فقال
الله لا اقبل
هبه بعد اليوم الا من فلان وفلان وفلان من
الناس
فعلى كل حال
هذا هو الخلق الخلق
انك اذا كنت ذا جاهل حتى من
ابنك حتى من
زوجتك مثلا حتى من كذا
الاب اذا
اذا نفسه في شيء عند ابنه العاده انه
الابن
راح يقول له لا
ماشي وكذلك الزوجه لانه بعلها لكن
الافضل دائما انه الانسان
اذا طلب الشيء
او ابدا رغبته في شيء عند احد ان يبتاعه
بالثمن والمفروض برضو
صاحب هذا الشيء
لا يابى
هذا المال يعني ما يذكر على انه لا لازم
تاخده لا
بو تكسب وهذا يحصل كثير يعني
تدخل
مثلا عند دكانه حدا وتدخل
وانت الامام الجامعه وانت صاحب جاه او انت
كذا عالم وما شابه ذلك
فالاصل انه الناس لا خليها علينا
لكن هذا جيد وطيب وبارك الله فيهم لكن
هذا ليس مقاما لذلك
لانه لو الواحد بده يعطيك شيء ما بستناك
لما انك تيجي تطلب هذا الشيء هو بجيبه من
عند نفسه
ولذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم منع
الهبات والهدايا لعمال
لعماله صلى الله عليه
وسلم يعني ياتي
احد بعثه رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
لياخذ الزكاه مثلا من الناس
فالناس يقولوا
تفضل هذا الزكاه وبرضه خذ لك النعجه او
النعجتين هذول الك مثلا
بس هديه ما بدنا شيء
هذا خطر هذا خطر على الدوله
وخطر على
الحكومه انه يتداخلها الغش
والامور هذه والرشوه وهذه شبه رشوه
شبه رشوه يعني مثلا بيجي صاحب الزكاه ياخذ
الزكاه
فهذه لك والله خذها لك فياخذها وبعدين
السنه الجايه برضو هذه الك كالعاده يا
سيدي واللي بعدها وبعدين اللي بعدها يقول
والله السنه هاي كانت صعبه
ومش قادره اوفي شو بده صاحب
العامل يعمل بده يكافئ كله لا خلص ما عليش
المره هذه وهان دخل الظلم
في
العمل فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم حصل هذا
معه كما في الصحيحين عاد احد عماله
استعماله رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
على الزكاه
فرجع الى بيت مال المسلمين وقال هذا لكم
وهذا لي هديه وهديتها
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قام على المنبر
وانكر ذلك ايما انكار
وقال لو كانت هذه هديه
ينتظر في بيت ابيه وامه حتى تاتيه هديته
يعني اذا كانت هديه كان اجتك مش وانت عامل
عند الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لم اتتك
وانت قاعد في بيت ابوك وامك
هذا شان الهديه مش شان الهديه
مع ذكر او ما ذكر
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حرص على ان يبتاع هذه الارض من هذين
الغلامين اليتيمين حرص على ذلك خاصه وان
هذا الشيء ليس خاصا به بل هذا للمسلمين
نحن لا نريد ان يرى احد ان له حقا زائدا
على اخيه المسلم خاصه في بيت الله خاصه في
بيت الله لذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذكر
حد العطاء في سبيل الله وفي البئر الذي
اراد ان يبتاعه من اليهود فقال من يشتري
هذا البئر ويكون
دلوه كدلاء المسلمين يعني في هذا البير ما
يجي بعدين ويقول لا انا من اللي اشتريته
انا اللي تسببت فيه وانا اللي بنيت وانا
عملته
دلو يكون اكبر او اكثر من دلاء المسلمين
لا هذا هو الشرط
فابتاع هذه الارض منهما لكن العلماء
عندهم قاعده يقولون
الاكتساب لا يمنع من الاحتساب
الاكتساب
لا يمنع من الاحتساب ايش يعني هذا الكلام
يعني مثلا
هذان الغلامان
اللذان ابتاع او باعه هذه الارض للنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
صحيح اخذوا حقهم واخذوا
اجرهم في هذا لكن هذا لا يمنع انه يكون
عندهم اجر عند الله سبحانه وتعالى ايضا
كذلك الذي مثلا يعمل على الزكاه او حتى
المجاهد مثلا او العلماء هؤلاء يعطون من
بيت مال المسلمين هذول مكفولين
المسلمون
يتحدون على كفاله هؤلاء العلماء
والجنود في الجيش
ياخذون اجرهم حتى لو كانوا اغنياء
يقول الله تعالى
وفي سبيل الله يعني انما الصدقات للفقراء
والمساكين قال وفي سبيل الله في سبيل الله
يعني الجهاد والجهاد قسمان قسم
باللسان والبنان وقسم بالسيف والسنان
فهؤلاء العلماء طلاب العلم كذلك الجنود
والجيش هذول حثوا حتى لو كانوا اغنياء
ياخذون حقهم من بيت مال المسلمين
ليتفرغوا لخدمه المسلمين
لكن هذا لا يمنع ان يكون لهم اجرا عند
الله سبحانه وتعالى هم اكتسبوا صحيح لكن
احتسبوا هذا الاجر عند الله ولا هم اجرهم
مثلا
الواحد يجيب عمال مكاول انه يبني المسجد
مثلا او يرمم المسجد ويكتسب ياخذ حقه لكن
هو
بنيته يقول هذا مسجد وانا اعمل فيه على
انه مسجد هو يكتسب ويحتسب الاجر عند الله
هذا لا يمنع من هذا
يقول وفي روايه انس بن مالك فكان فيهما
اقول كان فيه نخل وقبور المشركين وخرب خرب
يعني بيوت هافته مهجوره فامر رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم بالنخل فقطع وبقبور
المشركين فنبشت
وبالخرب فسويت قال فصف النخل قبله
وجعلوا عبادتيه حجاره يعني اللي بتسند
الحائط حجاره قال فكانوا يرتجزون يعني
ينشدون
شيئا من الشعر ورسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم معهم وهم يقولون اللهم لا خير الا
خير الاخره فانصر الانصار والمهاجره
يعني مع بعض وينشد وهذا الشيء وهذا مما
يشد عزيمه الواحد هو بيشتغل وهو مسافر ما
فيها شيء كان الصحابه يفعلون ذلك
قال شرع الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم في
العمل مع اصحابه وضرب اول معول في حفر
الاساس
الذي كان عمقه ثلاثه اذرع
الذراع
[Silence]
واذرعتهم كانت بجوز اكبر من اذرعتنا يعني
اجسامهم كانت اكبر من اجسامنا لكن على كل
حال كل
قول
مترين واشي عمق هذا الاساس
ثم اندفع المسلمون في بناء هذا الاساس
بالحجاره والجدران التي لم تزد عن قامه
الرجل الا قليلا يعني جدران المسجد ممكن
تطلع من فوقها
ماشي كانت قصيره المفروض هي بس ايش ما كان
محدد للصلاه ونحاول
لانه
مثلا الدواب والهوام وهذه الاشياء ما تدخل
على المسجد هذا هو الاصل لكن المقصود انه
هذه حدود المسجد هاي هذه الجدران
وهذا شيء بسيط جدا يعني
قال
والجدران
لم تزد عن قامه الرجل الا قليلا
باللبن
الذي يعجن بالتراب ويسوى على شكل احجار
صالحه
للبناء
فالجدران كان
يعني
الاساس
وكذلك الاركان من ان
محفور لهذا الاساس وبعدين
الجدران كانت
من اللبن ياخذوا الطين
المنحوت احنا بنقول له حاجه برضو نفس
الشيء ويطبخوه في
الشمس ويشكلوا على
شكل الطوب وبعدين يبنوا طيب شو المشكله في
هذه المشكله كل ما تمطر الدنيا بدك تظل
ترمم وهكذا كان
يعني المطر كان
يؤثر في المسجد لكن في المكان اللي هم فيه
المطر قليل هذا شيء
يحدث مرات في السنه
فبعد المطر وبعد هذه الاشياء يقوموا
بترميم المسجد وتنظيف
في المسجد
يقول وفي الناحيه الشماليه منه اقيمت ظله
من الجريد على قوائم من جذوع النخل
ظل يعني سقف هيك شيء يتظللوا فيه كانت
تسمى الصفه الصفه يجمعناها يعني الظلم
مكان المظلل
اما باقي اجزاء
المسجد فقد تركت مكشوفه بلا غطاء
اكثر المسجد كان ما في غطاء ما في عليه
سقف في مكان
في شمال المسجد كان مثقف
بورق النخل طيب هذا المكان المسقوف الصفه
لماذا
صنعوا هذا
لانه قبل كانت في الاصل الى الشمال صح ولا
لا
يعني اول ما وصل المدينه اول سنتين كانت
القبله الى بيت المقدس هي كانت الى بيت
المقدس وبالنسبه لهم على شكه الشمال فكان
هذا المكان
كان ليقف فيه الامام
والخطبه وكانت مظلله لكن الحين لما تحولت
القبله
بعد تقريبا 16
شهر من الهجره وصارت
صارت القبله الى مكه صار الحين
صفه وراهم الصفه صارت وراهم لانهم كانوا
يصلون الى الجنوب شكت الجنوب الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم قال في حديث ابن عمر
ما بين المشرق والمغرب قبله يعني المهم
المغرب على يمينك
مشرق على شمالك واللي قدامك قبله مش لازم
يكون شيء يعني دقيق واهي وهذا بالنسبه لهم
بالنسبه لنا الحديث ايش ما بين الجنوب
والشمال قبله صح لانه
احنا بنصلي الى شقه الى جهه المشرق يقول
ان ابواب المسجد فكانت
ثلاثه
باب في مؤخرته من الجهه الجنوبيه
هذه عشان يدخل
منه
النساء
وباب في الجهه الشرقيه
وكان
يدخل منه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم بايذاء باب بيت عائشه
وباب من الجهه الغربيه يقال له باب الرحمه
او باب عاتكه
وهكذا كانت الصلاه في المسجد صلى الله
في مسجد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
النساء لهن باب والرجال لهم باب
والاصل انه النساء
والرجال لا يتقابلوا
في المسجد الا نادرا الرجال للامام
النساء للخلف صف النساء يبتدئ من الحائط
الخلفي صف الرجال يبتدئ من
الحائط الامامي من وراء الامام
والصفوف تبنى هكذا لذلك يقول صلى الله
عليه وسلم خير صفوف الرجال
اوائلها
وخير صفوف النساء
اخرها ليش لانه النساء
اللي جايب بدري اول واحد يجي او المتقدم
هذا بده يصلي
في الصفوف الاولى والنساء العكس
يبتدئن الصفوف من الحائط الخلفي
يقول وبني لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
حجر حول مسجدي الشريف الحجر
عباره عن الغرفه لكن ليست من اللبن
تكون من
البيت
لتكون مساكن له ولاهله ولم تكن الحجر
كبيوت الملوك والاكاسر والقياسره بل كانت
بيوتا
من ترفع
عن الدنيا وزخارفها وابتغت دار الاخره فقد
كانت كمسجده
مبنيه من اللبن والطين وبعض الحجاره وكانت
وقوفها من جذوع النخل والجريد وكانت صغيره
الفناء
قصيره البناء ينالها الغلام الفارق
الفارع بيده قال الحسن البصري وكان غلاما
مع امه
خيره مولات ام سلمه قد
كنت انال اول سقف في حجر النبي صلى الله
عليه
وسلم بيده
يعني السقف
قريب يعني على قد الحاجه
ويلمس السقف
وهكذا كانت بيوت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
في غايه البساطه بينما كانت المدينه تشتهر
بالحصون العاليه التي كان يتخذها
عليه القوم
اباهيا بها في السلم واتقاء بها في الحرب
وكانوا من
بها يضعون لها اسماء يعني بعض البيوت ما
كانت حتى بيوت خرجت عن حال كونها بيوت
وحتى قصور وتسمى حصون وحصن حصن فلان وحصن
فلان يعني حتى في الحرب الجيش ما يقدر
يدخلوا
لشده هذا البناء
وقامته كما كان حصن عبد الله بن ابي بن
سلول كان يسمى مزاحم وقالوا مزاحم يعني
حصن عبد الله بن ابي وكما كان حصن حسان بن
ثابت رضي الله عنه يقال له فارع
ننتقل ايضا الى الاذان
كيف كان
ابتدا الاذان طبعا في مكه ما كان في
اذان لانه
كانوا مضطهدين في مكه وكانوا لا يستطيعون
ان يشهر
الاسلام ويظهر
شعائر الاسلام
ولذلك هاجروا
فلما وصلوا الى المدينه
واسسوا المسجد
الان قالوا كيف
نجمع الناس على المسجد طبعا ما في ساعات
اصلا في ذاك الزمن
ساعات كانت نادره جدا كانت عند الرومان
ساعات
يكون بالشمس وهذه ما تكون ساعه على ايدك
يعني او ساعه تحملها معك هذا ساعه في
ساحه
تذهب تنظر كم الساعه في هذه الساعه كذلك
كان عند فارس بعض
بعض
ما
يؤقتون
ساعات النهار به كانت ايضا بعض ساعات
كبيره ضخمه مصنوعه
من
وتعمل الماء
والبخار لكن هذه الاشياء
هي كانت نادره جدا الناس
كانوا متصلين
جدا
بالنجوم والشمس والقمر
وينظرون الى السماء ويعرفون الوقت يعرفون
الزمن في السنه من النجوم يحتاجون بالنجوم
ينظرون الى الشمس ويدرون من موقع الشمس
في اي فصل هم وفي اي ساعه هم وفي اي وقت
من
السنه هم
كانوا هكذا متصلين
بهذه الاشياء ولذلك لما نقرا
في القران ان الله عز وجل يقول
في الشمس والقمر
جعلهم الله سبحانه
وهو تعالى
لنعلم عدد السنين والحساب الناس كانوا
يعرفون هذه الاشياء ويتعلمونها يحتدون
بالنجوم يهتدون
بالشمس
وعندهم اتصال بالشمس والارض وكانوا قريبين
جدا من عمل الله المباشر
طبعا في هذا الزمن
اكثرنا جد يعني اكثر
اكثر المسلمين
بجوز خاصه في الدول الغربيه والدول التي
ما يعرف كيف يتيمم مثلا ما يفهم كيف يتيمم
الا لما بمرض وبقدرش يقوم حيله هذيك
الساعه بتعلم التيمم لماذا لانه
ولا مر عليه ولا يوم في
حياه قطعت عنه الميه
وهذه نعمه
وايضا هذه محنه هذه محنه عظيمه
لان الناس الرفاهيه
بتسبب ايش
بتسبب الكفران
تبع الذين ظلموا
فيه وكانوا مجرمين والله عز وجل
كثيرا ما يذكر في القران
ان من الاسباب الرئيسيه على كفر الكافرين
الرفاهيه
والثروه الفاحشه
ورغد العيش في الدنيا هذا ينسى الانسان
كثيرا
ويقطع اتصال
له بالله لكن الانسان لما بجوع يومه
اليوم لما بيكون عايش في نوع من الخشونه
فهذا هذا اقرب الى التواضع لله سبحانه
وتعالى ليس هذا معناه انه احنا يعني بنضم
في الحضاره بعض الناس يعني
تحمس واهي
فالقصه هي نعمه صحيح احنا ما ننكر هذا لكن
هذه الحضاره التي اصبح الناس عبادا لها
يعبدون الحضاره عباده
يعني يجعلون الحضاره ايش معيار معيار
التقدم
معيار التقدم للبشر
ما هو
معيار التقدم للبشر سلامه العقل
والفطره
وسلامه الادب هذا معيار التقدم
للبشر حتى لو كانوا في خربات حتى لو كانوا
فيه
الواحد لو كان في خصه في الصحراء لكنه
لكن فطره سليمه وعقله سليم
وكلامه سليم
وفكره متوازن
وادبه راقي
هذا متقدم في البشريه ما هو هذا الذي
يجعلنا
البشر ايش
يعني مميزين عن عن الدواب والهوام
لكن الانسان لما يكون متقدم في الحضاره
عنده تليفونات وعنده كل هالشغلات والزلمه
يعني وصانع كل هالاشياء لكن اصبح
ما يستطيع يميز بين الحق والباطل ولا
يستطيع يميز حتى بين الذكر والانثى
الامور متداخله مش واضح ايش اتذكروا وايش
الانثى
هذا هذا
يكون رداء في البشريه وهذا التخلف وتاخر
في البشريه
لكن الناس كثيرا ما يجعلون معيار
التقدم للبشر
والتطور هو تطور
الحضاره هذول جماعه متطورين وهذول جماعه
متخلفين
لا
غلط الله عز وجل ذكر هذا الميزان في
القران وذمه
قال
فاما الانسان اذا ما ابتلاه ربه فاكرمه
ونعمه فيقول رب
اكرما
واما اذا ما ابتلاه فقدر عليه رزقه فيقول
ربي اهاننا كلا
بل لا تكرمون اليتيم هذه الاهانه الاهانه
لما الناس لا يهتدون لمثل اكرام اليتيم
ولا يحضون على
طعام المسكين
وياكلون التراث اكلا لما
ويحبون
المال حبا جما هذه هذا هو الخذلان
فاما التقدم الحضاري جيد حلو جميل لكن
كثير من هذه الاشياء
التي
هي تعتبر من التقدمات الحضاريه
مما نتمتع بها مات وعذب افواج وجماعات من
الناس عشان هذه الاشياء تصلنا ناس
استعبدوا رسميا عشان كثير من هذه الاشياء
يتمتع بها الناس وعلى كل حال فاذا كانت
الحضاره هي المعيار
وهي المقياس
لتقدم البشري
فهذا شيء عجيب اكثر مئه سنه اكثر قرن سفكا
للدماء
هو القرن
العشرين الميلادي
اكثر من 120
مليون نسمه
اهدي ردمها
بالباطل
والظلم في الحروب والطاحنه
وفي الجوع وفي الاشتراكيه وفي هذه الاشياء
وهي كذلك اكثر مئه سنه تقدم في البشريه
وحضاره في البشريه كانت في ايش برضو القرن
العشرين
يعني
لما احنا كثير من الناس يعني ما زال
يتباهى بالصعود الى القمر وفعلا هو شيء
يعني
عجيب يتعجب منه الانسان هذا الانسان
الوضيع كيف استطاع ان يصل الى القمر
شيء عظيم
تقدم فكري
لكن
تاخر اذا كان على حساب تاخر الخلقي ما
بدنا اياه
يعني
طلعنا على القمر ونسبه
الفقراء في الدوله التي صعدت على القمر
جماعه منهم طالعين على
القمر وفي الارض تقريبا عشره في الميه
ما عندهم شغل ولا عندهم بيوت كمان
وكان
تعلق في
المحلات وحتى في الباصات وكذا ما يدخل
اسود هنا ولا يدخل كلب هنا في نفس الوقت
يعني اي تقدم هذا
التقدم ان وافق الخلق جميل لكن التقدم على
حساب الخلق لا
الحين صار صحيح
عنا تقدم
وتواصل وشيء عظيم لكن اكثر هذا التقدم
استخدم في الخير ولا في الشر
نشوف الانترنت
الحين بقول لك اربعين في الميه من
الانترنت خذ هذه الاربعين في
المئه بس للاباحيات والعياذ بالله
اربعين في الميه
ومع هذا التقدم اصبح الان نسبه الطلاق اقل
احواله احسن احواله 75%
وكذا
ذلك مع هذا التقدم
وتزاحم الرجال والنساء والاختلاط في
محلات العمل
كان هذا يعتبر تقد
ما
حررنا المراه فلما قاموا بهذا التحرير
ماذا حصل
حصل يعني
الفحش انتشر والزنا انتشر
والعلم رفع واصبح الرجل ليس كالرجال
والانث
كالرجال
والدنيا اختلطت ودخلت في بعضها
سبب هذا كله
كثير من الناس يعني
تنظر حتى الى مثلا شعر القوم الى قصص
القوم هذا هذا يلخص